there are so many new beauty products
being released
all the time so we gathered some of the
most hyped from the last month to test
for ourselves
first up we have the fenty beauty bright
fix eye brightener concealer i feel like
i was confused as to what this
actually was because the shade range
actually had normal concealer shades and
what i would consider more corrector
shades
so i went with the peach one to use as a
corrector slash brightener under my
concealer
i guess it's supposed to conceal and
brighten and correct
i did like the brightening effect with
this although it is more subtle
i feel like it's super lightweight and
blendable it's not a thick consistency
at all so you can layer it up if you
want that's what i try to do
however i don't think the effect is that
impressive or i can say it's worth
25 i was very intrigued by this kbd
beauty
mod con liquid gel blush just because of
the term liquid
gel the texture of this is very bizarre
it's very thin and it feels like nothing
i can't even explain it well
but i was nervous to put this on
foundation because i felt like it was
gonna break it up
it didn't i actually liked this way more
than i thought i was going to but it
is a little sheer for me i did end up
adding more but the problem when you do
that is that it adds more shininess
which i didn't love
but i don't hate this i'm gonna say that
26
for it feels excessive nyx came out with
this lip lingerie
xxl matte liquid lipstick which reminded
me a lot of its
shine loud high shine lip color only
without the gloss
nyx please shorten your product names
it's basically that but just a more
matte liquid lipstick i'm a fully
converted gloss girl now so applying a
liquid lipstick did have me stressed out
but the formula is actually pretty nice
i did one thin layer which i think is
key for products like this because i
find that they do not layer well but one
layer was all i needed for full coverage
i ate i drank and i wore this lipstick
for over eight hours and it stayed
looking good
it's pretty transfer proof i did see
some fading on the inside of my mouth
but overall i think this is great
for people who are into this sort of
thing
i was so excited for this maybelline fit
me tinted moisturizer because i love the
fit me line
and skin tints are so popular right now
but this sucked
so bad i'm so disappointed off of the
face the texture honestly felt really
nice and hydrating but then i started
applying
and it dried down so quickly i couldn't
blend it in
i was beating my own face with my sponge
trying to get it to move and it didn't
i completely removed it and reapplied it
again but it still was not the most
flattering on my skin
i just think it made my texture worse
and also caked up in some areas and
overall just looked
very not good don't buy this one
next we have the givenchy prisma libre
loose powder i feel like i said that in
spanish but it's supposed to be french
i'm gonna start off by saying i really
liked this but that is not me saying you
need a 58
setting powder i'm just saying if you
were looking
for a 58 setting powder i would get this
one
the multi-colored powder thing looks
cool but they all kind of blend into one
pretty translucent shade
i think this actually did a nice job of
smoothing out my pores and it set my
makeup without making me feel dry
i did feel like there was some
illuminating effect which is what i
think the green and purple powders are
for
but this has a very perfumey smell which
i hate i choked
several times let's ban scents in makeup
thank you so much
and lastly we have another weird blush
this is the bite beauty daycation
whipped cream blush
i feel like the worst part about this
blush is the packaging
it's so hard to get any product out and
when you do it just kind of shoots out
so you get so much product and kind of
waste it
but i do like the texture it's kind of
moussey and the color of the blush
itself is very pretty
it's glowy but i feel like it's a little
too metallic for it to look like
natural dewiness if that makes any sense
i do feel like the metallic-ness
enhanced my texture a bit but it wasn't
too bad i just think that for 32 dollars
i've tried
better liquid blush formulas but you can
actually use this on the eyes and i like
it more as kind of a cream shadow than i
do as a blush